[Musique]
de son côté dans le petit bourg danger
david le youtuber agriculteurs a baissé
ses cultures pour plonger dans l'inconnu
aujourd'hui je rends visite à olivier
sur sa ferme
original et plutôt inattendu car il
élève ici des âmes ce lieu s'appelle une
asinerie je rejoins là olivier qui est
en train de donner à manger à son
troupeau il va nous expliquer tout ça
l'asinerie un élevage en plein essor
depuis une vingtaine d'années à
l'origine de ce boom inattendu
la production du lait d'ânesse dont les
vertus bien connue dans l'antiquité
était tombé dans l'oubli
et à part la barre olivier fait partie
des pionniers de ce retour en grâce est
les ânes c'est son dada c'est l'heure de
la collation lots david salué l'idée qu
est-ce qui va manger alors là est un
petit peu dans j'ai un petit peu de maïs
aplatit voilà ça c'est sa petite ration
de tous les jours voilà c'est ton âne
reproducteurs s'appelle darius il a
maintenant six ans donc il entier 1
c'est à dire que lui il me sert
principalement au niveau de la
reproduction
maintenant on va laisser tranquille où
on va retourner à l'écurie pour aller
voir les femelles là-bas et puis
s'occuper d'elle une asinerie c'est un
matriarcat agricole ici les alès sont
littéralement dorloter on considère que
le stress a un impact négatif sur la
production
alors l'heure du repas à chercher les
âges c'est sacré voilà la légende
raconte que cléopâtre immergé
quotidiennement son corps dans des bains
de lait d'ânesse des siècles plus tard
c'est baudet du poitou perpétue la
tradition et le savon produit par
olivier aurait des vertus rajeunissantes
tient là on va aller les chercher parce
que là j'ai l'impression que si elle
pouvait sauter par dessus la barrière le
ferai c'est parti ça farine c'est pas
quand même le bal à laisser partir et
les nets
allez go go go go go go go c'est là-bas
le terrain de jeu des ânesses laitière 9
hectares on peut parler de luxe et de
confort dans ces conditions allez vous
cherchez vous cherchez à l'est pas
combien d'années alors en tout et pour
tout confondus elles sont 24
quand je dis elle ses talons les élus
jacques lui les malades dans le groupe
la vie de ce que je propose c'est
peut-être qu'on y aille voir les trois
années ce qui nous attend pour la traite
on va la traite ok ça marche
[Musique]